[Musique]
il maniait les ciseaux comme nul autre
et avec cet instrument cm réussissait à
créer des oeuvres époustouflante de
réalité du bricolage porter un niveau
artistique que personne n'a égalé au
québec des oeuvres fragiles qui sont
devenus son gagne-pain vraiment faire ma
vie et ça montreuil où l'éphémère qui me
feel me plains pas mais j'en suis très
heureux parce que ses sculptures étaient
des prouesses née d'une imagination
débordante d'une attitude qu'il tentait
de transmettre ce qu'ils voulaient
c'était pas pour faire comme lui il
était à créer important pour lui devenir
créateur créatif dans notre vie de tous
les jours partout tout le temps
il a réussi avec du papier à faire un
mozart a fait relâche à guînes à faire
des oiseaux et puis titres ordinaires il
leur a donné une âme mais au fond je
crois que c'est parce que monsieur la
fortune lui même que j'ai bien connu
avait une âme ne doit pas passer un
humaniste il aime l'être humain
sincèrement profondément pour ce qu'il
est dans toutes ces imperfections dans
toute sa complexité dans toutes ses
contradictions il disait souvent les
êtres humains il faut les amis pour
malgré leurs différences mais dans leurs
différences laisser partir cet humaniste
difficile pour la famille la fortune sa
conjointe ses enfants petits enfants et
même une arrière petite fille n'ont pu
lui donner un dernier câlin avant qu'ils
ne déposent les ciseaux à jamais ce qui
est un peu surréel dans le contexte
qu'on vit c'est qu'il est mort seul
parce qu'à cause la coved on peut pour
accompagner les gens qui meurent ça fait
c'est un plus sûrs et à l'heure que lui
était très présent pour tout le monde
claude lafortune à supporter son talent
au delà du terme de sa vie jusque dans
nos mémoires il si carla oliveira radio
canada montréal